[موسيقى]
نعم ميسون نحن في قلب المشهد اولا اولا
سيارات الشرطه
المتزايده صف طويل لا يكاد يحصى عدد
المشاركين من عناصر الامن في ضبط الوضع
على الارض الغاضبون من بين الاكراد
ينتشرون في الشارع الذي وقع فيه الاعتداء
على المركز الثقافي الكردي وفي كل الاحياء
المجاوره له طبعا ننتقل من مشهد عناصر
الشرطه كما تشاهدين الى الشوارع التي
تحاول الشرطه
ضبط الوضع في هانتقدم نحو الشوارع التي
ينتشر فيها طبعا هنا اغلقت كل
شوارع طبعا حركه السير مضطربه الناس هنا
لا يفهمون ما حصل ويسالوننا ما الذي يحصل
تحديدا
دعوات للغاضبين الاكراد للتجمع مجددا في
هذه الجاده التي سندخل اليها مجددا وكنا
غادرناها على عجل خلالها مراسله مع الحدث
قبل دقائق المواجهه
قد تتجدد هنا الغاضبون الاكراد
امسكوه بجانبي الجاده هنا وهي جده في قلب
العاصمه الفرنسيه
يقطعون الجده
باكواب من النفايات كما تشاهدين ميسون
والاعداد الكبيره من الغاضبين الاكراد
توزعت على الاحياء والشوارع المتفرعه عن
جده
ستراسبور كما تشاهدين المصور صبحي ينقل
المشهد كما هو
والقوى الامنيه الفرنسيه تحول عند مدخل
هذه الجاده جاده تستراسبور في باريس في
دائره العاشره تحديدا
خروج الغاضبين الاكراد منه هذا المكان من
هذه الجاده نحو شوارع وجدات مجاوره
بعد المحل كما تشاهدين اختبا العاملون
فيها خلف الزجاج
والبعض الاخر من المحل التجاريه التي فوجئ
العاملون فيها بما يحصل اغلقوا ابوابها
تماما البعض محتجز داخل محل اخرى لم يكن
بالامكان ان تغلق ابوابها فورا لانها فوجئ
بما حصل تشاهدين عناصر الشرطه يحاولون
ازاله
عوائق ويتعرضون لمقذوا فات من قبل
متظاهرين اذا ننقل المشهد المواجهه كبيره
وهناك مقذوفات بالحجاره على عناصر الشرطه
التي ترد عندها الجانب الاخر
[موسيقى]
قنابل مسيله للدموع سنحاول الانسحاب مجددا
لان الوضع تعقد وتطوره